大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
晚上八點,
波蘭的一個客廳,
電視上播著一部好萊塢電影,
畫面裡有男主角,
有女主角,
有一個七歲的小孩,
還有一個老警長,
可是他們每一個人開口的時候,
你聽到的都是同一個中年男人的聲音,
平平的,
沒有起伏,
一句接一句把所有人的臺詞唸完,
那個念稿的人是被要求這樣唸的,
念得越平越好,
觀眾才能自己去判斷角色現在是難過還是生氣,
整個波蘭大概就那幾個聲音,
通常是低層年長的男性,
而又有兩個在那種電視前面長大的年輕人,
後來一個進了Palantir
一個進了Google
然後他們兩個都辭職了
去做同一件事
讓機器把臺詞唸得像人
這是史丹佛CS153
這門課的第九堂到第十三堂
五位講者
站的卻是同一個位置
今天我們就把這五堂課一起上
那兩個從小看這種電視的波蘭人
一個叫Marty Staniszewski
本來在Palantir當部署策略師
另一個叫Piotr Dabkowski
本來在Google當機器學習工程師
2022年
他們在倫敦開了一家公司
叫11 Labs
你給他一段文字
他把文字念出來
今天這家公司的年化營收超過5億美元
年化營收的意思是
把每個月收入乘以12推算的一年規模
不是已經入賬的錢
他在講臺上講了一件
跟我原本想的不一樣的事
他說讓電影公司願意把這個技術
放進工作流程的
不是聲音變得多像人因子那一關
早就過了
真正卡住的是
你沒有辦法指揮他
你把稿子丟進去
他自己決定怎麼念
你不喜歡就再生成一次
再讀一次
一直到最近
他們才做到
讓你可以像片場的導演那樣講話
這一句重念一次
細節新一點 同時再慢一點
模型早就夠好了
真正卡住的不是他會不會唸
誰有權利說這句唸的好不好
這門課的前八堂
我們在上集和終集上完了
上集那四個人回答的是同一個問題
權力集中在誰手上
終極那四個人回答的是下一個問題
那我還剩多少籌碼
答案是槓桿變得非常長
但是那個支點是租來的
到了第九堂
整個樓層換掉了
前八堂講的是
誰蓋得起這臺機器
這五堂講的是
機器蓋好之後
站在出料口的那個人
Andreas Blackman做影像
他是Black Forest Labs的共同創辦人
Amit Jain做影片
是LumaA的執行長
Matthew Staniszewski做語音
Nickel Singel不談模型
他做產品
講的是人
最後一堂是授課者Angie Meeta
這五個人的位置完全不同
可是隻像同一句話
模型已經夠好了
卡住的是誰來說這個好不好
順著這句話往下走
你會走到一個答案
你能驗證什麼
你就擁有什麼
我們先從影像這一講開始
第十一堂的講者叫Andreas Blattman
他是Black Forest Labs的共同創辦人
那天他從德國的Freiberg連線進教室
他大學唸的是機械工程
2019年才轉進AI
他一開場沒有講技術
他請全班做一件事
他問
18個月前
有多少人試過丟一張自己的照片給模型
叫他幫你加一頂帽子
然後出來的那個人真的像你
逐字稿上寫著
整間教室只有一隻手
舉起來
這件事有一個名字
叫角色一致性
意思是你換個場景換件衣服
畫面裡那個人還是同一個人
而在那個時候
這是一個大家公認解不掉的問題
Bladman說了一句很重的話
他說如果每一次有人跟我講這個問題
永遠解不掉
這些模型太笨了
我就能拿到一塊錢的話
然後他補了半句
而這些都是非常聰明的人
包括這門課的一些講者
一個全業界的共識
在兩年之內整個翻掉了
那他們是怎麼解掉的
答案要倒回2019年
當時Blatman在德國海德堡
一個小實驗室念博士
指導教授叫Bjorn Omer
他們的對手是Google
和OpenAI的研究團隊
而他的說法是
我們的算力少非常非常多
他說那時候
光是生出一張256x256的小圖
都算挑戰
沒有錢
就只能問一個
別人不用問的問題
有沒有這種表示法
對人的眼睛來說
跟原圖幾乎一樣
但是資料量小很多
他們找到了
他說你其實是在訓練
一個壓縮模型
可以把它想成一個
學出來的JPEG編碼
JPEG就是你手機裡
照片的那種格式
丟掉很多你看不出來的細節
換到小很多的檔案
他們就先把圖片
壓進那個空間
在裡面把圖畫出來
畫完再放大回像素
這個東西叫潛在擴散
他後來的名字你一定聽過
Stable Diffusion
他之所以能在你自己家裡
那張顯示卡上跑起來
直接的原因就是
這群人當年買不起算力
Blatman這一講的主張
藏在一個很簡單的觀察裡
他說你現在看著我
你感知我的媒介是影像和聲音
這兩樣東西他叫做自然表示
因為它們的來源你控制不了
光來自太陽
河流的聲音本來就在那裡
文字不一樣
文字是人造的
他說如果你去量每一個符號
帶多少資訊
文字遠遠高過影像裡的每一個像素
原因就是它是人做出來的
溝通效率
演化太重要
所以我們把文字裡多餘的部分壓掉了
而奇怪的是
對學習來說
那些多餘的東西反而是必要的
你可以想想自己
還是嬰兒的時候怎麼學的
先是觀察
用聽的和用看的
然後在物理世界裡動手互動
大概五歲才開始讀字
他說一個三歲小孩的智能
跟一個語言模型的智能
是很不一樣的東西
所以他的結論是
從語言出發再往上疊別的表示
這個方向是錯的
應該回到人類真正的學習順序
先觀察再互動
真正把那個沒有人解得掉的問題
這套理論
是他們回頭看了一次使用者的資料
那一年他們在意大利辦團隊聚會
中間傳來消息
一個資源多很多的實驗室
剛發表了看起來好很多的東西
他說這種時候第一個直覺一定是
文呢
然後他給了一句每個人都用得上的話
一個好的領導者的標記就是
不要慌
保持冷靜
看資料
評估地形
再一步一步把計劃想出來
大量的使用者拿他們的文字生圖模型
去訓練一種叫RORA的東西
RORA你可以想成
給一個大模型外掛一小塊記憶
讓他記住某一個特定的人
或某一種風格
比較像貼一張便條紙
不是重新訓練
那些人訓練羅拉的目的
幾乎都一樣
為了讓畫面裡的角色
每一張都是同一個人
這代表使用者要的控制力
遠遠超過一句文字能給的
所以團隊的一個叫Dustin的人想通了
他們要做的不是更會畫圖的模型
是能編輯的模型
24小時之內
整個團隊的人力被重新配置
60天之後
那個模型出來了
使用者的日常操作
改掉了一家公司的路線圖
這也出現了整支影片的主線
主持人問Blatman
美感這種東西要怎麼驗證
我先把驗證這個詞講白沉是嗎
很好驗證
你寫一段檢查程式去跑
對就是對錯就是錯
可是一張圖好不好看
沒有測試可以跑
他的回答很老實
那需要大量大量的人類判斷
很累
而且非常取決於你問誰
同一張圖拿給一個
沒碰過影像生成的人看
拿給他這種看過無數張圖的人看
訊號完全不同
然後主持人把這件事變成一條通則
這是這五堂課的鑰匙
只要怎麼驗證的答案是看觀眾是誰
就代表這個系統的價值高度取決於它能不能為特定觀眾調整
而這正是開放權重進場的地方
開放權重的意思是
公司把訓練出來的參數直接給出去
任何人可以下載可以改可以在自己機器上跑
不是給你成品是給你原料和配方
所以他們可以跟一家大公司說
你想怎麼跳這個模型的偏好去服務使用者
你可以跟一個文化偏好完全不同的政府說
最後一粒鹿的控制權在你手上
那開放權重要怎麼賺錢
他們的flux一號不是一個模型是三個包裝
第一個叫Snail
德文的快
源泉開放給大家下載
第二個叫Dev
權重一樣公開
自己在家裡玩沒問題
可是要拿去賺錢
就得付費授權
第三個叫Pro
權重不公開
只放在截面後面
你付錢呼叫
而三個的差別不是大小
他說
這不像語言模型
有小中大三種尺寸
這三個一樣大
差的是步數
擴散模型畫圖
是從一團雜訊開始
一步一步把圖插出來
插50次細節
但是慢
他們用一種叫針流的技巧
讓小模型跟著大模型學
把50步壓到4步快很多
品質差一點
所以你買的不是不同的模型
你買的是不同的耐心
主持人幫他把
德國人的委婉翻成白話
不管你是誰多有錢
你要問把護欄拿掉
抱歉
護欄對所有人一樣
因為要當一個
大家能依賴的基礎設施
就不能對不同的人有差別待遇
Blatman承認
這確實讓公司少賺過
相當可觀的一筆營收
然後他說
那沒關係
講一影像我們往上抬一層
第十堂的講者叫Amy Chen
Luma AI的執行長
之前在Apple做過Vision Pro
這一講最值得聽的是
他一開場就承認自己壓錯過一次
還用了天真這兩個字
他當時的推論很漂亮
立體資料比影像多
影像又比文字多
那要做最聰明的模型
當然去收集立體資料
所以Luma出了一個App
你拿手機繞著東西拍一圈
他就重建出立體場景
然後他撞牆了
他說不管多少人用那個App
都到不了學會這個宇宙學校的規模
因為網路上寫字拍照拍影片的人
遠遠超過任何一家公司散播的數據的量
他學到的那句話最實用
你必須照我的資料在哪裡設計演算法
而不是反過來
他把這個教訓套到機器人身上
大家都要做動作系統
可是動作的資料在哪裡
他的原話是
網路上沒有一個動作的網際網路
文字和影片有整個網際網路累積了幾十年
可是沒有任何地方在記錄
一隻手把螺絲鎖進去
Luma後來做出的產品叫Dream Machine
2024年6月上線
你打一句話生一段影片
上線之後使用者很多
於是他們把按讚還下載的行為當成訊號
你們喜歡哪一隻模型就往哪個方向找
然後出現了一個很好笑的問題
阿密劍說這個訊號不是百分之百準的
因為有些人下載的是真的很爛的影片
下載回去是為了拿給朋友看
說你看AI做出來的東西有多爛
模型分不出這兩種下載
於是他把那些也一起學進去了
所以他們得再蓋一層
付錢請人來把這種東西一直一直挑掉
他接著講的這句話
更正了很多人對前沿實驗室最大的誤解
他說這時候一個前沿實驗室
真正的樣子才浮出來
他有資料有算力有演算法
但是他還有一大塊
是訓練員家教還有做標註的人
沒有那些人
這個實驗室是不完整的
你以為那裡面全是顯示卡
其實還坐著一整排
在替模型打分數的人
接下來是這一講最好的一段
而且他可以整個班去解釋這五堂課
Armit Jain說
大家想到影像模型就覺得
他們只是在產出漂亮的圖片
而這是全世界對這個領域
最大的一個認知落差
他要你先想想語言模型
語言模型產出的也只是文字
那些文字可以排得很美
你可以說這是一首詩
然後他其實什麼都沒說
可是同樣一批文字
也可以排成一個數學證明
他們最後都只是字
決定資訊含量
決定聰明程度的
是你怎麼把他們串起來
像素也一樣
你怎麼排列像素
決定了他們在傳達什麼
也決定了他們有多聰明
所以他的立場是
影像和影片模型
不是會畫圖的模型
他們是在用
另一種材料表達智能
就像有些人用文字思考
有些人用圖思考
材料不一樣
思考是同一件事
這句話重新設定了整個問題
如果影像也是一種語言
那今天這些模型不好用
原因就不會是
畫得不夠漂亮
那問題在哪裡
他的答案只有兩個字
真的很笨
他馬上補一句這樣
笨不是要罵人
是在描述一組症狀
他問
當你跟一個
你不覺得聰明的人
共識症狀是什麼
他們忘記你講過的話
你得一直重複同一件事
他們其實沒聽懂你的意思
他們是一個聽懂的仿製品
你講一句話
他們照字面解釋
可是那不是你的意思
他們可以做小事
你要求多一點就做不到了
他說
這就是今天所有的影片
和影像模型
他的類比更清楚
如果ChatGPT只能講一輪
你沒講完一句就要重開一次
那會多煩
沒有人會用
而那正好就是語言模型從研究專案
變成真正有用的東西的分界線
可以多輪對話
可以被你當場糾正
影像和影片模型還沒跨過那條線
這一講還有一句他自己標明有爭議的話
他說
擴散模型也在退場了
物理上規模撐不住
你可以把這句跟前面那堂放在一起聽
因為上一位講者
正是潛在擴散那篇論文的共同第一作者
同一門課 隔幾週
兩個人講了相反的話
那要怎麼把他變聰明
Amit Jain給的方向叫統一架構
也是不需要任何技術背景
他說Transformer其實不在乎你
為什麼資訊進去
真正出問題的是前面和後面
也就是編碼器和解碼器
所以他們要做的是
不管聲音影像文字還是程式碼
全部先編碼到同一個空間
然後在同一個骨幹裡面推理
他自己給的類比就是人腦
人腦處理視覺和聽覺
確實有不同的區域
但是那些只是編碼器
就像眼睛和耳朵
把光和空氣的振動都轉成同一種電訊號
所有資訊最後都進到大腦皮子
思考 推理 判斷
全部發生在同一個地方
他說這個架構他們花了大概一年
失敗過非常多次
他也順口評論了一款你可能天天在用的工具
Nanobanana
他猜那個東西還是兩座塔
一座負責生土
一座負責生製
中間只有一條很細的橋
這裡要加一個段數
那是他的推測
那家公司從頭到尾沒有公佈過任何架構資訊
那句話你聽他的觀點不要當成事實
那人在這套系統裡的位置在哪裡
阿米錢在課堂上
當場用Luma的產品生出一整份簡報
主持人問他怎麼做到的
他的回答不是模型
他說我們團隊裡有一個非常會做簡報的人
寫了一份大概50頁的文件
講什麼叫好的簡報設計
那份文件才是關鍵
模型負責畫
那份文件負責判斷什麼叫做好
他說城市設計師一直有一種槓桿
是藝術家從來沒有的
你寫一次城市
它會在所有人的電腦和手機上跑一次又一次
可是一個藝術家做出一個東西
只是一個東西就這樣
現在其他領域的創作者也拿到這個槓桿了
你把自己的判斷交給模型一次
它就能在不同情境下產出大量的東西
這句話的前半很勵志
可是他接的後半很冷
應該文人講出來
他說人的技能和創造力變得更重要
他會淘汰掉平庸的人
把真正厲害的人抬得更高
因為他們的作品會被重跑非常多次
同一個槓桿
兩個方向
你落在哪一邊
取決於你手上有沒有那份文件
這一堂最後有一段跟模型完全無關
有人問他AI會不會殺死好萊塢
他先把AI盛開
他說好萊塢現在是預設死亡的
而這跟AI一點關係都沒有
他的商業模式已經惡化了30年
疫情加速了他
然後編劇罷工是最後一根釘子
他接著說
好萊塢已經不拍電影了
好萊塢出錢
但是不拍
那在哪裡拍
希臘 加拿大 愛爾蘭
哪裡有稅務優惠就在哪裡拍
他把病因歸到一種心態
把一個系列當成一份資產
然後儘可能收租
哪一部大賣就拍二拍三拍四
他說他已經數不清有幾部復仇者了
他給的反例是串流平臺
一年做將近600部中等預算的東西
於是更多種類的故事被說出來
也就吸引到更廣的觀眾
這一段跟臺灣也接得上
我們自己也在做影視補助
他最後引了一句電影裡的臺詞收尾
不是觀眾有義務走進戲院養活好萊塢
是好萊塢有義務做出好東西讓觀眾想看
你不能怪你的客戶
好萊塢那個位置接到第12堂
Matis Daniszewski
一開始想做的就是配音
而配音要自動做完
需要三個模擬接力
第一個是轉錄
聽出畫面上是誰在講話講了什麼
還要把背景音樂分開
第二個是翻譯
把臺詞換成另一種語言
第三個才是合成
用聲音念回去
三個都不好做
他在動手之前
做了一件很土的事
打電話去問創作者和片場
如果自動配音做得出來
你有沒有興趣
對方的回答讓整家公司轉向
他們說有興趣
可是你能不能先幫我
做一件更簡單的事
我錄音的時候有幾段沒錄好
你能不能幫我修掉
或者直接用我的聲音
把稿子念出來這樣
我就不用站到鏡頭前面
所以在2022年
他們把整條管線
砍掉三分之二
只做最後一例
把文字變成聲音
聽起來像人
有情緒
而且只做英文
主持人把這個決定
這件事跟前面兩位講者同一個道理
資源有限的時候
你要盈靠的不是多做
是準確的少做
Stanislawski自己給了一條很好用的解題
把語音這幾年一年一年排出來
2022年他們解掉的是上下文
同樣一句話
如果它是一句開心的話
跟它是一段對話裡的一句念法必須不一樣
模型要先讀懂這一句
在什麼情境裡
2023年往外漲
變成多語言
多種聲音
也讓人可以複製自己的聲音
他們還做了一個聲音的試級
貢獻自己的聲音還能分到錢
2024年那一年
轉入模型終於做得夠好了
於是轉入翻譯合成三端
可以真的串起來
他們一開始最想做的配音
這時候才成立
你注意這個順序
他們最想做的事情
是在第三年才有能力做的
2025年的關鍵是速度
模型終於可以即時跑
於是語音代理人出現了
他得判斷你這句話講完了沒有
然後馬上接話
而到了2026年
題目變成怎麼把中間的延遲
再壓下去
一年一節
而每一節都不是聲音變好聽
是這個系統又多學會
一件本來只有人在做的事
那要讓模型聽指揮
難在哪裡
答案很無聊
Stanislavski說
難的地方是
你根本沒有多少資料可以告訴模型
這一段的念法是開心是難過還是緊張
網路上有海量的聲音
可是沒有人在旁邊標註情緒
所以過去一年
他們大量投資的是標註工程
先把資料伸出來
才有東西可以訓練
這跟上一堂AmyGen講的是同一件事
前沿實驗室裡最不像科技的那一塊
決定了模型能不能再往上一截
那個像導演一樣下指令的功能
時間要講精確一點
2025年中先出測試版
2026年2月才是正式版
Synergyowski還給了AI8G一個定義
比阿比芬的討論都準
他說這些工具應該是中斷到中斷
不是斷到斷
你先有一個想講的故事
用工具做出旁白然後去修
也許整段重做才拿到好成果
而他講的那種垃圾
是端到端的版本你打下去提示
他直接給你成品
既沒有一開始那個故事的輸入
也沒有中間反覆修改的過程
他講最好的工程判斷
是他選了一個不性感的答案
語音系統有兩種概法
第一種叫串接式
三個模型排隊接力
一個負責聽懂
一個負責想
一個負責講出來
第二種叫融合式
一個模型從頭報到尾
你一開口他直接聲出聲音
不經過文字
明顯比較快
而Stanislavski的結論是
接下來幾年串接式才對
理由是每個人都經歷過的場景
你打電話到客服改機票
他得先驗證你是不是你
把資料拉出來
要動到付款還得確認付款資訊
中間大概還會走一次雙重驗證
每一步都必須可靠
而且照著順序走
他說融合式就犧牲了這一塊
你很難追蹤每一步發生什麼事
也沒辦法給他護欄
至於速度他直接認輸
延遲最難
這裡融合式是贏的
可是我們的客戶是企業
要可靠度勝過延遲
這一段值得跟上一堂一起聽
MGN說要一個骨幹全部包進去
Staniszewski隔一週在同一間教室
說企業要的是接力
同一門課兩個相反的答案
而他們都有客戶
這一堂裡我最想留給你的
其實不是技術
主持人問Staniszewski
你在Eleven Labs做過最驕傲的事情是什麼
他講的不是營收也不是模型
他說是跟那些失去聲音的人合作
把他們的聲音找回來
見動症會讓一個人慢慢說不出話
後來的手術也可能拿掉髮聲的能力
而如果這個人在還能說話的時候
留下過任何一段錄音
哪怕只是一段家庭錄音帶
模型就可以從那段聲音裡學會他的音色
然後把他之後想講的每一句話
用他自己的聲音講出來
到目前為止
這件事他們已經替超過一萬一千個人做過
你可以想象那個畫面
一個人在鍵盤上打字
然後房間裡響起來的是他自己的聲音
不是一個機器人的聲音
這個數字是整支影片裡我最想讓你記住的一個
同一個技術你可以拿他做出很難聽的東西
也可以拿他把一個人還給他的家人
同一套技術還去了一個
你不會想到的地方
戰爭開打之後
烏克蘭政府面對一個很現實的問題
人在移動 機關在關門
那些要跑一趟才辦得到的事怎麼辦
他們做了一個叫DR的公民應用程式
這個字在烏克蘭文裡是行動的意思
把上百項服務全部放進子手機裡
而11Maps做的是
加上語音那一層
Stanislavski自己飛到基輔去工作
因為真正的難點不是
手機界面做得多漂亮
是那些不太會用科技
年紀比較大
沒有網路的人
要怎麼拿到同樣的服務
他們的答案很土也很好
讓那個人打一支電話就好
電話那頭是一個
聽得懂也講得出來的系統
他還觀察到一件跟技術無關
但是很值得操的事
在那裡每一個部位
都有自己的技術資源可以做創新
不必走繁文入節
各自往前推
一個在臺上講架構的人
講到最有溫度的兩段
一段是把聲音還給病人
一段是讓一個沒有網路的老人打了通一支電話
這一堂還有一句話
臺灣的觀眾特別該聽
銀行和電信這幾年一直在推聲紋認證
就是用你的聲音當密碼
而一個做語音模型的人在史丹佛的講臺上說
這天很多系統包括銀行還在依賴語音認證
我們認為這不是未來
你應該離開這條路
不要再拿它當認證手段
從治安的角度來看這是錯的做法
這件事有一個很具體的證據
2023年一位記者用的就是11Labs的免費方案
拿自己大約5分鐘的錄音
做出一段合成語音
打進自己的銀行
通過了聲音驗證
查到餘額和交易記錄
滿是被自己的聲音打開的
反過來也有很好玩的一段
他們跟一個慈善機構合作
只要偵測到一通來電
可能是詐騙集團打的
就把一個語音代理人
接上去跟對方講話
目的很單純
就是耗掉那個人的時間
同一個技術
一邊把假的聲音送進銀行
一邊用假的聲音去拖住騙子
五堂課裡有一堂完全不談模型
第九堂的講者叫Nikiru Shingo
創過三家公司 在Google當過產品管理總監
管過Hangouts
現在在Meta當產品副總 另外經營一個叫Skip的網路
他這一堂講的是人
也是全系列對觀眾處境講得最直接的
他先定義了產品經理
這個定義非常好懂
他說每一家科技公司裡
都有一群人負責做東西 有一群人負責賣東西
然後有一群人夾在中間
夾在中間的那些人 把你想做什麼 黏到要怎麼做出來上面
那就是產品經理
接著他畫了一張公司四個階段的地圖
第一階段是在找一個
真的有人要的產品
他的比喻是
專木取火
一直戳
希望冒出一點菸
這時候根本沒有產品經理
冒煙之後你聞到熱度
要做的不是繼續實驗
是冷靜下來
因為下一個客戶
不能拿到不一樣的產品
再來是超高速成長
既要把現有產品做大
又要開新產品線
而過去五年
做這兩件事的標準做法
只有一種
僱一大堆人
他講了一個自己搞砸的案子
Google曾經把好幾個通訊產品
整病成一個叫Hangouts的東西
那次整病就是他做的
他說那個決定的錯誤在於
它是一個大樓裡面的問題
不是使用者的問題
他問全班你們有誰會想
天啊我好希望手機上
只要一個App就能跟所有人溝通
我打賭你們每天都在用
好幾個不同的軟體
那全部是不同的App
可是我們在公司裡的信念是
我們有七套程式碼
七個產品
七套身份系統
整合起來一定比較合理
結果客戶根本不在乎
他給的對照組是另一家通訊軟體
只做純文字
把印度和鄉村地區做到全世界最可靠
等網路建起來之後
語音和視訊自然疊得上去
還有一個很好的反諷
Hangouts
後來又被分回兩個產品
難說Google教他最有用的一件事是
最好的產品一開始看起來都很爛
重要的是你改進得多快
Trump每六個星期出一個新版本
當時的IE好幾年才動一次
這一堂最好的一段是兩次舉手
Single先問全場
多少人對畢業之後找工作感到焦慮
幾乎所有的手都舉起來
然後問他這個問題
多少人正在用AI做東西
而且做得很開心
舉手的是同一群人
他停在這裡給了一個對照組
如果三年前問同樣這兩個問題
答案會反過來
焦慮的大概只有二三成
可是那時候我找不到一個
真心喜歡自己職位的人
為什麼
那時候是零利率年代
錢很便宜
公司排名固人
就算你只是中等能力
也會拿到好幾個聘署
可是那些工作全都是同一種形狀
有責任沒權利
他說產品這一行不管公司大小
你的工作就是把資訊包裝好
交給另一個做決定的人
如果你是想做東西的人
當一個官僚是很痛苦的
所以他的判斷是一個
你可能沒想到的好消息
現在的人壓力更大
但是更快樂
因為你不用再等工程師
等設計師
等老闆點頭
這一段跟前面幾堂接得很緊
前面講的是模型
把成本壓下去
這裡講的是
那件事落到一個人身上的樣子
有人問他
現代的產品管理裡
最沒有用的是什麼
他的回答分兩層
第二層很不客氣
他說很多公司
是用演戲在做產品的
你開一個大型的正式會議
會議上有一份簡報
那份簡報是一群副總寫的
你去問副總
副總說是我團隊做的
再往下是總監
總監熬夜把投影片拼起來
再往下全部都來自某一個30歲的人
跑的一個實驗
然後一大堆副總把時間全花在這件事上面
而最底下那個想出這個實驗的人
根本沒有出現在那個會議室裡
他說這就是今天軟體被做出來的方式
然後他下了一句判斷
我覺得這一整堂就靠這句話撐住
他說這場戲演不下去了
他自己在Meta的工作
大部分就是讀很長的文件
或者背靠背開會
而業界現在有一個很明確的趨勢是
是往完全不開會的方向走
有些團隊一個星期只去半天
理由跟上面是同一件事
那些會本來就是在演戲
把地面上發生的事一層一層往上傳
這件事現在有別的東西可以代勞
這一段是這一堂最冷的
我照他的原話講
他說最難受的那群人不在這間教室裡
是那些還可以但是
不算頂尖的建造者
在零利率的年代被升上去當主管
他們對該做什麼沒什麼意見
但是對資訊怎麼流動意見很多
他們現在看到AI會自己寫程式
他們有小孩
有年邁的父母三十幾歲
他們心裡想的是
我沒有時間
自己重新發明一次
他的結論是
最焦慮的房間不在這裡
是那些入行8到15年的中階主管
這裡要把分寸講清楚
他講的是
只會搬運資訊的那一層
不是所有的中階主管
他說那些實驗室面試的時候
不在乎你待過哪個牌子的公司
他們看得出來
一個人是不是在面試的同時
才在學工具
他還丟了一句
對名校生很有分量的話
品牌現在處在歷史低點
不過又要踩剎車
他在課堂上還說
產品經理的職缺
比歷史上任何時候都多
大型科技公司今年會裁掉三成到七成的人
這兩個我都對過公開資料
跟產品最相關的職缺
現在比疫情之前還低
各家公司實際的裁員比例落在2%到15%
那他給學生的答案是什麼
他先做了個算術
一個人這輩子可能工作40到50年
一份工作平均只待兩三年
所以你這輩子大概會有15到18份工作
他的結論是
你的職涯不是球賽的三節
是一本書的章節
他那家公司叫Skip
命名理由就是這個
他說最好的職涯建議是去想
你正在想的那一章的下一章
所以與其問第一份工作要做什麼
不如問你第二份工作要做什麼
第一份要怎麼安排
才能讓第二份選擇最多
他給的建議裡最重要的是系統思維
以前的問題是
這個東西要怎麼做出來
現在的問題是
假設他做得出來
那到底該不該做
他還畫了一條線
每隔幾年平臺就往上漲一層
從組合語言到編譯語言
腳本語言
到現在是用提示在寫東西
如果你懂這些層怎麼往上疊
怎麼把下面那層淘汰掉
那才是接下來唯一的求局
最後他講了自己的後悔
他說我當年應該少焦慮很多
除了你自己以外
沒有人真的在乎你的成績
我沒遇過任何一個僱主在意過
他還說非常後悔
沒有交更多朋友
最後一堂課
是這門課的授課者自己上的
他叫Enje Mita
創過一家做立體地圖的公司
後來被Disco收購
之後在創投機構ASU6J
現在開了一家叫AMP的公司
而這裡有一件事是
我做這支影片時才發現的
它會改變你怎麼看前面12堂
這一堂在播放清單裡排在最後
因為那個清單是按照上傳時間排的
可是它不是期末總結
它是開學第一週的課
他自己在開場就說了
今天我是這一季剩下所有人的開場暖場
接下來那些人才是你們的主秀
也就是說前面12堂
那些你以為排在他前面的人
微軟的執行長
OpenAI的執行長
黃仁勳
在時間上全部是後來才走進這間教室的
他們講的每一句話
其實都是在回答
開學第一週黑板上就寫好的問題
這門課四年前叫另一個名字
那時候選課七十幾個人
這一季是四百多人
所以接下來這幾段
你可以當成一份提前公佈的答案卷
Mita一開始就在黑板上畫了一張圖
而這張圖其實就是我們這三集的目錄
他說過去十幾年
垂著雲長出來
一個還算穩定的堆疊已經成型了
最上面是資本
前綴靈活
可以放進任何一層
往下是土地
電力
和廠房
也就是發電和蓋機房
再往下是晶片
再往下是雲
也就是讓晶片能被用起來的那層軟體
再往下是模型和代理人
然後是應用
拖的整件事是治理
安全
安全 治安 還有信任
你把這三集擺上去就會發現
上集講的是土地 電力 還有晶片
中集講的是資本
而這一集講的是模型往上到應用的那幾層
他管現在這個時刻叫大轉換
他說至少在我這一生
我不記得有哪個時候是每一層
假設都同時在被重新檢視的
而他接的話是給學生的
那給了你們巨大的機會
因為只有在不確定的時候事情才會改變
這張圖也解釋了為什麼這門課的講者名單
長得那麼奇怪
一個做核燃料的 一個做語音的
一個管治安的
因為他是照著這張圖一層一層把人請上來
接下來他做了一件我很欣賞的事
把兩個最常被亂用的英文詞用養狗講完了
第一個詞是強化學習
他說如果你養過寵物
或者有一個弟弟妹妹需要被教會不要進你房間
那你已經是一個成功的前沿模型訓練員
核心概念是你不告訴那個模型怎麼做
只告訴他你要他做到什麼
做到就可以獎勵
沒做到就不給
然後洗掉重來
第二個詞是上下文
英文叫context
那個詞常常被講得讓人聽不懂
他說你在公園訓練你的狗去撿球
那座公園就是上下文
就是環境
公園裡的人跑來跑去的小孩
草地下雨
這些環境因素都會影響
你能不能訓練起來
然後他用這個比喻
推出三個問句
幾乎可以拿去看整個產業
哪裡的進展會最快
哪裡的環境可以被
可靠的測量和驗證
程式碼可以寫測試
材料可以做實驗
誰會贏
那些對某一段環境有賭佔
而且守得住的
存取權的團隊
誰會輸
那些被鎖在
關鍵環境外面的團隊
最後這句你先記著
他馬上就給了一個活生生的例子
他講的是一個叫WindServe的程式編輯器
2025年春天
市場上傳出OpenAI要收購它
四個星期之後
Anthropic幾乎切斷了WindServe
使用者對自家模型的存取
而且只給了不到五天的通知
Media說這種事在這一行不常發生
不會沒有預警
就把界面關掉
但他說這完全說得通
如果你的競爭對手需要用你的模型
需要那一段環境
而且可以從你怎麼幫助你想搶的客戶身上
把本事學走
那就是外洩
他說對業界人來說這件事非常清楚
我一點都不意外
但是很多人開始改變看法了
然後他把這件事接回那張堆疊圖
如果你是應用層的公司
一直以為上面那層會永遠供應智能給你
那個假設在那一天停止了
這個故事後來還有結局
比他講到的那一半更完整
那筆收購最後破局
Google付了一筆授權金
並且帶走執行長
剩下的公司被另一家新創買下
一個編輯器
兩個月之內被分成三塊
他接著問全辦
有多少人聽過Cloud Act
組織稿上寫著0
他說那得把它列成指定閱讀
這條法律是美國在2018年通過的
業者必須交出他持有或者控制的資料
不論那份資料放在美國境內還是境外
也就是說資料放在哪一國的機房不是重點
重點是那家公司受不受美國管轄
我要講精確一點
因為他在臺上的說法有點過頭
這條法律並沒有新增監控權限
要拿到內容還是要有相當理由的搜索票
那是針對特定賬戶的形式程序
不是隨便撈
不過有一點反而讓他的論點更成立
可以抗辯的機制要看對方是不是簽了協議的國家
而美國目前只跟英國和澳洲簽
歐盟還在談
所以他說這就是為什麼歐洲會長出自己的模型公司
城市碼那種環境不敏感
開發者不介意送到某個雲端
可是國家的紀錄
國防這種環境就得鎖在自己的機房裡
那你就需要一個可以在自己機器上跑的開放權重模型
臺灣這幾年也在炒
資料能不能放境外的雲這條線
你會覺得很熟
然後他講到了整支影片的那條主線
他說有一派人認為
只要環境對 算力夠
代理人怎麼都學得會
他不會材料科學
就叫他自己蓋一個環境去練
他說他站在另一邊
他的原話是
目前並不清楚強化學習
有在他練過的任務之外類推出去
他看到的是
生活是雜亂的
進展最快的永遠是容易驗證的領域
在城市這種可以跑測試的地方
你會看到一種很窄的超級智能
可是世界上有一大堆不容易驗證的領域
他舉的例子是美感美愛
好的美感
可驗證的判準是什麼
沒有人答得出來
他還講了一件糗事
三個星期前
他把自己寫的一篇宣言傳給一位朋友看
對方30秒之後回他
你這是用Cloud寫的吧
他說沒有
對方說我不信
他承認自己是先寫大綱
再叫模型展開
從那之後
他們公司有一條內歸
不互相傳AI生成的文
而下一段
他放出一整組歷史圖表時
自己補了一句
這些圖表是我請Cloud幫我拉的
數字有錯不能怪我
這一堂最後的主張
跟很多人的直覺相反
他說過去四年
我數不清有多少人跟我說
你為什麼把這麼多時間
花在算力上
那是商品
給公司一點錢
自己去雲端租就好
然後他說不太對
他給了兩個判準
第一個是可替代性
電是可替代的
100萬瓦到哪裡都是100萬瓦
可是今天的算力不是
連同一家廠商不同世代的晶片都不能互換
城市在這一代跑得好
半一代要重調
第二個是可預測性
我們對用電已經有幾十年
穩定的預測算力沒有
研究團隊很難推理自己下個月要多少
訓練是尖峰式的
現在小規模玩演算法
有效才衝上去跑大的
推論又是走起性的
白天很多人用
晚上沒人用
拿他放出一張圖
那是一款兩年多前的晶片租金曲線
2025年10月的低點
大約一小時1.7美元
今天大約2.5美元
一個兩年多的老東西
租金不但沒掉還在漲
他那天早上還收到一位
剛募到大錢的創辦人訊息
說我們算力短缺
急需晶片
他回
要幾張
什麼時候
對方回
現在就要
價格不是問題
那怎麼辦
Mina的答案不漂亮
但很具體
他說歷史告訴我們
要把一種被少數人窩著的稀缺資源
變成大家都拿得到的
只需要兩樣
一樣是標準
交流電和直流電是標準
網絡的傳輸協定也是
都是我們反覆聚在一起達成的協議
同意一套格式
不管在哪裡大家都能用
另一樣是機構
因為到某個規模的人一定會不一致
總得有人去協調
把大家對齊到標準
他最後那句最重
標準不會自己來
他需要機構去執行
把權力從靠囤積得力的人手上
重新分配出去
改成優先考慮公共利益
這句話回答的是上級留下來的空缺
上級Sam Altman說
很少被討論的一件事是
我們具體要怎麼分配算力
然後他承認沒有答案
這一堂在他走進教室之前
就給了答案
Meta最後給學生留了兩個問題
要怎麼讓運算
完成一次和平的轉換
還有你在這裡面是什麼角色
他還說有太多領域只有你懂
也只有你驗證的了
因為那是你的執念
你的品位
你的文化
那才是你最有價值的東西
五個人站在五個不同的位置上
最後給的是同一個答案
模型已經夠好了
真正卡住的是誰來說這個
好不好
而順著這句話往下走
你會走到一個很簡單也很不容易的結論
你能驗證什麼你就擁有什麼
上集問的是
權力集中在誰手上
中集問的是
那我還剩多少籌碼
這一集的答案是
那根珠來的槓桿上屬於你的
是你判斷得出好壞的那一段
而那些沒有驗證器的地方
美感 品味 愛
正好也是暫時還沒有人拿得走的地方
最後問你一個問題
在你自己的工作裡
有哪一件事是你看得出好壞
而模型還看不出來的
留言告訴我
這是正門課的最後一集
上集 中集 下集
我都放在同一個播放清單裡
喜歡的話訂閱 AI Notebook
來起通知
我們下次見